[Музика]
привіт, привіт усім, настав час
уроку англійської, мене звати Наталія Лесько,
давайте почнемо, тому сьогодні ми продовжуємо розмову
про різні види спорту та обладнання
. Почнемо з домашнього завдання, яке я
вас попросив зробити, щоб завдання було написати
речення, які види спорту ви любите та  вам
не подобається використовувати приклад, який мені подобається,
тому що це або я не люблю, тому що
це так, давайте послухаємо приклад
одного з наших студентів. Я люблю футбол,
тому що це весело, я не люблю крикет,
тому що він нудний, тому який вид спорту зробив
ви чуєте так футбол і крикет ми
не обговорювали це на нашому попередньому
уроці, тому давайте зробимо це сьогодні
футбол це командна гра, а
також гравці грають у футбол і
крикет, це інша гра,
я покажу вам картинку  сьогодні трохи пізніше,
тож давайте перейдемо до першого завдання
для вас, давайте переглянемо
спорядження подивіться на малюнок 10 секунд
назвіть спорядження
десять секунд тепер давайте перевіримо, чи є
Matt be a snorkel дивіться гідрокостюм D ласти
електронний шолом F  ковзани G палиця H a шайба I
шолом J сноуборд K a удар назад l
боксерські рукавички та M тренажери молодці
, і давайте переглянемо п'ять видів спорту,
тому номер один - це йога номер два -
підводне плавання з маскою, номер три хокей
номер чотири сноуборд і  Кікбоксинг номер п'ять
молодці, тож давайте поговоримо про
ці п'ять видів спорту, і вони хочуть, щоб
ви використали приклад, подивіться, чому
б нам не займатися йогою, ми займаємося йогою, давайте
займаємося йогою, щоб усі ці варіанти були
можливі, і ми запросимо людину  займатися
спортом з нами, то давайте спробуємо ще раз
чому б нам не зайнятися йогою, повторюйте за мною
чому б нам не зайнятися йогою, молодці, ми
знову займемося йогою, ми будемо займатися йогою ідеально
і останній давайте ще раз займатися йогою
давайте  чи йога скажи, що відповідь
буде це чудова ідея,
повторюй за мною, це чудова ідея, і
ти опиши, що тобі потрібно для цього
конкретного виду спорту
для йоги, нам потрібен килимок, тож візьми свій килимок,
і я зустрінуся з тобою через п'ять  хвилин
повторіть після того, як я візьми свій килимок, і я
зустрінуся  ви за п'ять хвилин
добре зроблено зараз ми закінчили з йогою давайте
спробуємо з снорклінгом подивіться
давайте займатися снорклінгом або чому б нам не зайнятися
снорклінгом або третій варіант
, ми підемо снорклінгом, і відповіді
це гарна ідея,
тому замість чудового  ідея, ви також можете
сказати, що це гарна ідея, це також
можливо, а потім ми описали, що нам
потрібно для підводного плавання, давайте візьмемо ваш
гідрокостюм і ласти, і вони
зустрінуться з вами через п'ять хвилин,
тож давайте спробуємо цей діалог, яким я
буду  a і ти будеш B легким спочатку
давайте спробуємо давайте поплавати з маскою, візьміть свій
гідрокостюм і ласти, і вони
зустрінуться з тобою через п'ять хвилин,
молодці, давайте розглянемо ролі, які ти
збираєшся бути, а я збираюся  будь B, тож
ти починаєш, це хороша ідея
ідеальна, тому ми закінчили з підводним плаванням,
давайте з хокеєм, давайте
спробуємо поглянути, чому б нам не пограти в хокей,
чи пограємо в хокей, чи давайте
пограємо в хокей, і відповідь буде  це
чудова ідея отримати ковзани, і я зустріну
вас  n п'ять хвилин, тож давайте зіграємо цей
діалог, ти a I'm B, це чудова
ідея,
ідеальна, давайте перейдемо до
сноуборду, давайте подивимось, чому б нам не
покататися на сноуборді, це чудова ідея,
візьми свій сноуборд, і я зустрінуся з тобою через
п'ять  хвилини давайте розглянемо інший
приклад, тож ми підемо кататися на сноуборді
, це хороша ідея, візьміть свій сноуборд,
і я зустріну вас через п'ять хвилин
ідеально, давайте з кікбоксингом
подивіться,
давайте займатися кікбоксингом, це чудова ідея,
візьміть свої боксерські рукавички, і вони будуть
зустрінемося за п'ять хвилин, давайте спробуємо
інший варіант, чому б нам не зайнятися
кікбоксингом, це гарна ідея,
візьміть свої боксерські рукавички, і вони зустрінуться з
вами через п'ять хвилин, тож давайте потренуємося
зі мною,
я а, а ти Б, давайте спробуємо
займіться кікбоксингом, отримайте свої боксерські рукавички, і
вони зустрінуться з вами через п'ять хвилин,
дуже дякую, зараз є завдання для
вас подивіться, нам потрібно піти зі
спорядженням, тому подивіться на фотографії, які
я даю вам десять секунд, напишіть  слово
вниз тепер давайте перевіримо так ню  mber one
я одягнув, подивіться на фотографії що
це
так, ласти молодці
і мій ммм-хм, що це за трубка з трубкою Браво
і добре зануритися в тепле море, тому я
надягаю ласти і трубку і пірну
в тепле море зараз  ти намагаєшся ідеально,
давайте з номером три я надів
пару
гоголівських окулярів, отримав мій мм-хм і почав
кататися по снігу,
що це за сніг, Берт молодець, давайте
прочитаємо все речення, я одягнув
окуляри, дістаньте сноуборд і почніть
кататися по снігу тепер твоя черга,
будь ласка, прочитайте речення добре виконано,
давайте з номером два, тепер я одягаю
шолом і ковзани і виходжу на
лід, тож давайте прочитаємо все речення, я
одягнув шолом і ковзани, і йду
виходь на лід, тепер твоя черга
Браво, давайте з номером чотири, я
одягнув пару кросівок і свої боксерські рукавички,
і я почав наносити
удари назад, тому давайте прочитаємо речення
ще раз,
я одягнув пару кросівок і мій
бокс  рукавички і вони починають бити і
добре зроблено.
Браво, я хочу, щоб ви вгадали вид спорту,
так що ласти та трубка, що це таке так,
це підводне плавання номер два шолом
і ковзани та лід, так що це хокей,
добре виконано
номер три окуляри для сноуборду ми
не використовуємо  окуляри для підводного плавання з маскою, ми використовуємо
їх для сноуборду, тут добре зроблено, так що
тренери боксерські рукавички б'ють і
б'ють по боксерській груші так, це
кікбоксинг.
Браво, тепер давайте більше
спорту подивіться, є кросворд і нові
слова, чи
можна знайти кілька слів номер один
дуже знайомий так, це бадмінтон, але
що щодо решти, ці слова можуть допомогти
вам подивитись у
нас водне поло повторюється за мною
водне поло добре
бадмінтон молодець
катання на ковзанах повторіть будь ласка катання на ковзанах
крикет це дуже популярна гра в
британській йозі  ти знаєш це слово
аерохокей не аерохокей, а аерохокей
візьми Вандо ще раз візьми рану о, молодець
і керлінг, тому всі ці слова
для вас нові, давайте разом з кросвордом
я  Я збираюся написати їх у
списку відповідно до цифр, тож давайте
почнемо з номера один, подивіться на
картинку, що це так, це
бадмінтон, давайте напишемо
слово, давайте напишемо слово разом.
два, що таке номер два,
подивіться на хлопця, на якому він носить шолом
і біту, тож він грає в крикет,
давайте запишемо це, чи можете ви порахувати,
скільки тут букв одна два три чотири
п'ять шість сім
дякую, давайте перейдемо до номера три
подивіться на  хлопець, який він тримає щось на
зразок палиці чи мопі, і він на
льоду,
це керлінг, давайте запишемо це
слово, це дуже цікава гра, ви
б'єте об камінь, і він ковзає по льоду,
і судять вони вважають, як далеко це заходить
це дуже цікава гра, тому
ви знову вдарилися в камінь, і вона йде на лід,
керлінг повторюйте за мною керлінг, добре
зроблено, давайте йти далі, у нас є номер чотири,
вибачте,
номер чотири це йога Браво, а що щодо
числа п'ять, чи можете ви вгадати слово, з якого воно
починається  Подивіться
так, візьміть одні двері, тут є три
різні слова, тож давайте запишемо їх,
давайте повторимо, візьміть одні двері ще раз,
візьміть попередження, о, дякую
номер шість, що це, подивіться
на жінку, на якій вона носить ковзани і
танцює на льоду  так катання на ковзанах добре
[Музика]
номер сім, давайте подивимося,
гравець у воді і він
тримає м'яч, тому він грає у водне поло, давайте
запишемо це,
а останнє слово
номер вісім - аерохокей, тож давайте
перевіримо слова, чи  зроби те саме чи
інше молодець зараз скажіть мені, будь ласка,
згідно з картинкою я люблю
хокей, а ти
скажи мені, що тобі подобається хм, я не люблю
брати одні двері, але я люблю дивитися
катання на ковзанах це для мене дуже цікаво
і коли  Я подорожую на узбережжі,
я люблю грати у водне поло, це моє
улюблене, а як щодо вас, кажете свої
речення, дуже дякую, давайте
продовжуємо, для вас є вікторина, тому
подивіться, у нас є слова «грай і ходи»
та різне обладнання, щоб ми  потрібно т  o
закінчіть речення, я даю йому десять
секунд,
запишіть слова,
тому давайте разом перевіримо, подивіться
на мої відповіді, якщо ви дуже уважні,
ви повинні помітити, що тут є деякі
помилки, тому швидко
знайдіть помилку та давайте виправимо їх,
тому давайте перевіримо  разом номер один, коли
ви катаєтесь на сноуборді, вам потрібен сноуборд
і гідрокостюм правильно ні, перш за все, вам
потрібно сказати іди, а замість цього гідрокостюм
що вам потрібно
так окуляри, щоб захистити вас від вітру,
давайте подивимося на номер два, коли ви
граєте на льоду  хокей, тобі потрібна ключка
і шайба, я думаю, що це
правильне речення, тож це єдине
правильне,
давайте з номером три, коли ви займаєтесь
йогою, вам потрібні боксерські рукавички,
перш за все, боксерські рукавички, це
невірно, тому що  боксерські рукавички
це у множині, і у нас є артикль
повітря, який означає один, тому для йоги нам
потрібен правильний килимок, але що ми говоримо про
йогу грай або йди так ми говоримо робити так
давайте скажемо правильне речення, коли ви
робите йо  ga, вам потрібен килимок, добре зроблений
номер чотири, коли ви займаєтеся підводним плаванням, вам
потрібні ласти трубка і окуляри,
знову ж таки, у нас є окуляри в множині,
і у нас є неправильний артикль a,
тому точно нам потрібен гідрокостюм і що
нам робити  з підводним плаванням ми граємо в
снорклінг ні ми займаємося підводним плаванням ні ми йдемо
підводним плаванням давайте скажемо правильне
речення, коли ви займаєтеся підводним плаванням, вам потрібні
ласти трубка і гідрокостюм,
а останній, коли ви займаєтеся кікбоксингом, вам
потрібен удар кулаком назад і Метт виправляє ні,
що ми робимо  займайся кікбоксингом іди
грай, ми робимо кікбоксинг добре, і що
нам для цього потрібно удар у спину та боксерські
рукавички, тож давайте скажемо правильне речення,
коли ви займаєтеся кікбоксингом, вам потрібна
боксерська сумка та боксерські рукавички, а тепер правильні
відповіді для вас.  подивіться і
скажімо, речення таке: коли ви катаєтесь на
сноуборді, вам потрібен сноуборд і
окуляри, повторюйте за мною дякую, коли
ви граєте в хокей, вам потрібна ключка
та шайба Браво, коли ви займаєтесь йогою, вам
потрібен килимок  молодець, коли ти
займаєшся підводним плаванням, тобі потрібні ласти, трубка з трубкою
і гідрокостюм, і останній, коли ти
займаєшся кікбоксингом, тобі потрібна боксерська сумка і
боксерські рукавички, дуже дякую, я
говорю першу частину, а ти закінчуєш
речення, коли займаєшся йогою, тобі потрібно добре
Готово я зустрів, коли ти займаєшся підводним плаванням, тобі
потрібні ласти трубка і гідрокостюм
Браво
хм, коли він йде зараз на борт,
тобі потрібен сноуборд і окуляри, добре,
коли ти граєш у хокей так, тобі потрібна
ключка, шайба і остання, коли
ти йдеш  з кікбоксингу вам потрібна боксерська груша
та боксерські рукавички, добре зроблено, тому пам'ятайте, що
ми закінчили останній урок, і ми
почали сьогоднішній урок із фраз, які мені подобаються,
тому що це та прикметник, тож давайте також розглянемо
ці види спорту,
наприклад, я не знаю  люблю керлінг, тому що
це нудно, або я люблю квандо, тому що
це справді захоплююче, я люблю кататися на ковзанах,
тому що це красиво, я люблю водне поло,
тому що це весело, а
аерохокей, я люблю аерохокей,
тому що це весело ти  n також скажіть, що я люблю
аерохокей, тому що це захоплююче, хм, я
люблю бадмінтон, тому що це дивовижно,
і я не люблю крикет, тому що він
нудний, тому ви можете вимовляти свої речення та
своє домашнє завдання до наступного уроку,
готуйтеся з новими видами спорту та обладнанням
.  слова ми збираємося написати
короткий диктант і я чую, як
дзвонить, це означає, що нам потрібно
припинити урок дякую дуже
до зустрічі наступного разу
[музика]
ти